- (speaking foreign language)
(lively music)
Präänik, no word for it in English,
old people candy from way back,
like way, way back.
- Präänik pa, okay, how
do I pronounce this?
- Kinda nutty.
Maybe like peanut butter-y.
- Kinda feel like donut-y,
a little biscuit-y.
- Mmm.
- Soft on the inside,
crunchy on the outside, it's perfect.
- Tastes like the healthy
version of something good.
- If I was a kid, I could see myself
just licking the outside of this.
- (speaking in foreign language)
Raspberry flavored safari cakes.
- This looks like a bath soap.
Which means I'm excited to eat it.
- Like how delightful,
this looks like it's
out of a fairy tale.
- Mmm, smells like perfume.
- Smells like sour cream or something.
- Ooh, they're soft, ooh,
they're like marshmallow runes, ooh.
Now there's a texture I've never felt.
- Because it's kind of
hard to tell visually
what the texture is, maybe
this'll give you a little hint.
Just like...
You get it?
- (speaking foreign language)
Praline candy with pistachio nuts.
- I like pistachios, I like
chocolate, I like Estonia,
this is gonna be great.
- This looks like a tootsie roll.
And on the inside, it's got
pistachio stuff, I guess.
- Now that's a nice
looking piece of candy.
- Took me about 10 seconds to figure out
out whether this was good.
My conclusion, it's okay.
- It's very gooey and gets
kinda like all over your mouth.
Like I think like in
between my teeth and my gums
is just a lot of chocolate and
pistachio just sitting there.
- We gotta use pistachios in more candies.
Maybe pistachios are
expensive, I don't know.
- (speaking in foreign language)
Which is birch tree candy.
- Kaseke which from the package looks
like it translates to log.
- It's got leaves on it.
That's never a good sign of a candy.
- Don't give up hope.
It may look like poop, but
it may not taste like poop.
- I have no idea what
I just put in my mouth.
What is this?
- Birch tree flavor?
So it really is a log.
- Oh, it tastes like a tree, huh?
Well, I'll be damned.
Trees are delicious.
- So if I lick a birch tree,
it's gonna taste like this?
- I think that's cool.
I think we invented chocolate for a reason
because trees don't taste very good.
Nice try to keep the tree thing alive.
- I wouldn't waste calories
on this, let's be real.
- No American equivalent of this.
We need to step up our
birch tree snack game.
I wonder if these taste like
what life in Estonia is like.
- Super moist and moist on the inside.
- This is very moist, the moistness.
I don't know why I keep
talking about how moist it is.
That's what impresses me about this thing.
It's super moist on the
inside and I'm surprised.